All right everyone.
Welcome to the webinar today.
We will be talking about a new functionality
within the E-utilities API that supports accession.version
identifiers.
We have materials for this webinar, the PowerPoint
and a few bells and whistles that will be
available for you at the FTP site and you
can get to that through the coursesandwebinars
link on the screen here and there is a direct
link also, the go.usa.gov URL.
With all of that said, I will start the webinar.
What we're talking about today is actually
the fourth webinar in a series of webinars
about changes that have been going on with
the way that NCBI deals with sequence identifiers.
Today we are happy to announce that the E-utilities,
our main API for the Entrez system, is now
able to fully support accession.version identifiers,
both as input and output.
What I want to do is give you a quick overview
of how that works and point you to some examples.
As I said we have been doing webinars about
this since the past summer starting back in
July.
there are three webinars we put out there
about various topics relevant to the changes
in identifiers for sequence records here at
NCBI.
Feel free to go back and take a look at those
if you haven't had a chance to view them.
Very short and sweet, the change that is happening
is that gradually NCBI is phasing out an identifier
called G.I. number.
These are integer identifiers that have been
used for many years for sequences but for
a number of reasons we are phasing those out
and transitioning to a situation where we
will be using accession.version identifiers
as the primary identifier for sequence records.
Since so many of our tools, including the
E-utilities, have been dependent upon GI numbers
in the past, it was critical for us to be
able to offer these APIs in a form that would
not be dependent upon GIs but would be dependent
upon a different identifier set, accession.version.
The main thing that we introduced as a parameter
called idtype that will control this.
It works a little bit differently in the various
e-utilities.
I will go through esummary, efetch, esearch,
elink . And then, the final prize package
at the end is how you get sequences that don't
have GIs and what is that about and how you
can think about that problem going forward.
Let me review quickly again a little bit more
detail about what's changing so everyone is
on the same page.
The GI numbers are being phased out.
What this means is they are not being deleted.
It's important for people to understand we
are not deleting GI numbers but we are not
going to assign GI numbers to a growing number
of newly deposited sequences.
If you have a sequence that has a G.I. number
it will continue to have that G.I. number
and will always be retrievable by that number
for the foreseeable future.
What's happening now is, as more and more
new studies come in, those will not be assigned
GI numbers so if you stick with just G.I.
space you won't have access to more and more
of the new data coming in.
A few things that have already been happening
are that the GI numbers are no longer visible
on the flat file formats on the web or in
FASTA definition lines, including in the BLAST
databases.
So you won't see the GI numbers in those presentations
and again just to be clear those numbers are
still in the raw data files, for example,
the ASN.1 or the XML.
They will not be shown in the more public
web friendly presentations.
After March 15 of this year none of the releases
of GenBank or RefSeq will contain GI numbers
in their presentations in the flat file or
in the FASTA that you get off the ftp site.
That's another thing to be aware of.
That's what's happening.
Let's talk about E-utilities and what effect
it has on them.
For those of you not as familiar I wanted
to go over what the utilities are and what
they do and their function and how they depend
upon the unique identifier.
The E-utilities work in all of the Entrez
databases, from PubMed to the sequence databases,
medical databases, whatever, the e-utilities
function across a wide variety of identifier
spaces.
What they do is a few functions.
ESearch can take a text query and return back
to a set of these unique identifiers, that
correspond to the result set.
Those unique identifiers, uids, can be passed
to additional E-utilities to retrieve those
records.
For example, I can pass a UID to ESummary
to get the record summary, or docsum, which
is a short abbreviated metadata about a record
that you commonly see as search results on
the web.
Alternatively I can take a UID and pass it
to EFetch which would download the full data
record in a variety of formats.
PubMed you can get abstract, citation, Medline,
etc., ASN.1, XML.
For sequences you can get FASTA, flat file,
XML, ASN.1, etc.
Efetch is a great utility for getting the
data down once you have the identifiers in
hand.
ELink is another powerful utility that lets
you take identifiers from a given database
and find linked records in another database.
For example I want to find the PubMed literature
associated with a sequence.
I can link from the sequence records to PubMed.
I can link from nucleotide to protein, etc.,
etc.
Elink also talks in this UID space.
One set of UID's in and another out.
Finally, epost is essentially an upload utility
that takes UIDs and puts them onto a temporary
storage facility that we call the Entrez history.
And this is a server that stores temporarily
your search results.
Then I can take the results from that history
and pass those to fetch or to summary or to
link for further processing.
I think it's pretty clear as you look at the
diagram that all of these utilities either
output UIDs or accept UIDs as inputs.
It's critical to the function of this API
that the UID space be well determined.
For sequence records, talking about nucleotide,
protein, EST and GSS databases, and Popset,
the UID has always been the G.I. number, the
integer identifier.
Not anymore.
You can continue doing that but now all of
these utilities will do the same thing for
accession.version.
It's a very powerful upgrade in the functionality
of these APIs, it extends their scope significantly
and we'll talk more about that towards the
end.
The set of UIDs is now a set of accession.version
identifiers.
You have the option, it's important to understand
that you can continue to use GI numbers but
you have the option to use accession.version.
I listed there the primary databases that
this affects.
Let's step through them and talk about what
would happen.
Luckily ESummary and EFetch get an upgrade
that is silent.
You use the ID parameter as input for the
UID's.
So in the first URL showing there, ESummary,
and the database is nuccore, there are two
UIDs there.
That's a traditional ESummary call.
For EFetch it would be the same kind of call,
same UIDs, but I might put rettype equals
fasta to specify I want the FASTA format.
What you can do now is instead of using those
integer identifiers, the gi's, you can put
accession.veresion.
If you put in accession without a version
you get the most recent version of that accession.
That just works.
You don't have to do anything else to your
call.
You don't have to add an ID type parameter
or anything else.
It just works.
This is great and you can just start using
this
For those of you who've been using these APIs,
you may realize that EFetch has been able
to do this for many years.
It has been able to accept accession.version
for several years along with GIs, it continues
to do that.
In this regard EFetch has not changed.
ESummary has changed.
It has never been able to accept accessions
as input but it can now.
That's what's happening with ESummary and
EFetch.
Pretty simple.
You don't have to do anything, you can just
use accessions now.
ESearch is more interesting because what ESearch
can do now is output data as accession.version.
What ESearch does is takes a text query, like
foxp2[title] AND human[organism].
I want the human sequences for foxp2.
Before, I would assemble this call.
What that would give me is a list of GI numbers
back.
What it does now is you have the option, if
you add the ID type parameter, and give it
the value acc, so &idtype=acc is appended
to that same search call, you will get something
different.
This is what you get different.
The default without using ID type is a list
of the top 20 GI numbers.
Unique identifiers that match your query.
Those should be nucleotide GIs.
If you use ID type equals acc, you get back
the accession.versions.
This is cool.
You get the accession.version as if the GIs
don't exist.
You get them back directly and can use them
for further processing.
Elink is going to behave in much the same
way.
It takes sets of identifiers as input and
gives you sets of identifiers as output, in
the same or a different database.
A very simple example is here's a nucleotide
G.I. number and I want to find the protein
that it encodes so I say dbfrom=nuccore, db=proetin,
and there is my ID.
I would expect to get back the protein G.I.
that is associated with this.
If I use ID type equals acc, append that to
the URL, now it allows me to do two things.
I can have an accession number as input.
So I don't have to use a G.I. number and I
will get back accessions in the output.
Here's a comparison of the XML that I would
get back from those two calls.
If the ID type is not set, the default is
essentially GI numbers.
Here's my nuccore dbfrom, here is the id in
nuccore, the link is to protein, here is the
ID number for protein, 34577063.
That's the G.I. number of the protein linked
to the incoming nuccore record.
But if I use ID type equals acc.
What you see on the right side, is that the
NM_ record, 001126.3, is now linked to NP_001117.2.
so I get the accessions back immediately.
ID type equals acc is required for ELink and
ESearch if you want to get the accessions
in the output.
Before we do a little bit of playing with
this I want to talk about some expanded scope
that the e-utilities now have access to because
of this change.
It's important to understand this so you don't
run afoul of the way the data are restructured
now and be aware that these changes will continue
happen as things progress.
we have sequences that don't have GIs.
That's an issue for a number of reasons because
a sequence without a G.I. is not part of the
Entrez system.
It's not part of Entrez Nucleotide, nuccore,
or Entrez Protein or any other Entrez database.
That has several consequences.
ESearch cannot find them.
They are not indexed in Entrez, so esearch
has no access to them.
They do not have document summaries, they
are not in Entrez so ESummary cannot retrieve
them.
They have no Entrez links so ELink cannot
perform links between gi-less objects.
Also they cannot be placed on the Entrez history.
For example, EPost cannot handle or process
them.
For those of you who are e-utility aficionados,
if you use ESearch with usehistory=y, it won't
work for a gi-less sequence because they can't
be put on the history, they are not part of
Entrez.
But EFetch can now download them.
EFetch has become an odd man out in that it
now has a special function, that it has access
to the whole world of GI-less sequences through
their accession.version.
All NCBI sequences, whether they have a gi
number or not, have a accession.version identifier
and EFetch now can access all of them.
This is brand-new functionality that we have
never had before, that API access to all of
these GI-less sequences that still have a
accession.version.
So what are we talking about?
A lot of WGS and TSA.
So whole genome shotgun datasets and transcriptome
shotgun assembly datasets.
Many of these data sets do not have GIs for
their contigs.
They may have a G.I. number for their master
record but they will not in many cases have
GI numbers for all the congtigs.
Ultimately most new sequences, eventually
almost all, will be like this.
They will not have GI numbers but they will
have accession.version.
It's important to understand that this is
the future and where things are moving so
that accession.version becomes the main identifier
that you can depend on.
A cardinal example currently is the Norway
Spruce project, CBVK.
This is a very large project with over 1 million
contigs.
Because of the size it was not assigned GI
numbers.
It has one G.I. number that represents the
master record.
So CBVK and all those zeroes, that single
representative record, which has no data in
it except metadata, that one record is indexed
in Entrez.
If you search for Norway Spruce in Nucleotide
you would find that record but all of the
million contigs are not available to you from
entrée and have not been able to be available
to from the API e-utilities.
They are now.
One question that folks might have is how
do I check if a sequence has a G.I. number
or not?
The easy way to do this programmatically is
to use ESummary because it will immediately
return to you in error tag telling you that
this accession does not have an identifier,
a gi identifier.
And you can do that with a mixed bag of input
and esummary will very politely tell you which
ones work and which ones don't.
At this point that's our recommendation as
to the best way to check.
Esummary is fast and it can process thousands
of records in a given URL, so it's a good
way to parse through a big list if you want
to find out what has a G.I. number or not.
There are other approaches if you have massive
projects and you are concerned about using
ESummary, write to us, talk to us, we can
give you some additional help.
What I'm going to do now before I go to this
slide is do some demo.
We will go through a few calls so you can
see how they work.
Also this little Perl script, an incredibly
simple little script, I've put on the ftp
site in case any of you want to play with
it.
I'm just going to explore the calls a little
bit.
I'm going to actually show you what the Perl
script looks like.
That's it.
All it does is post a URL and I have an array
here of eight sample URLs.
You can explore this and edit as you want
and play with this functionality.
The first URL is an ESummary and that will
get back two sequence records specified by
an accession.
This is something we haven't been able to
do in the past, so to run this little script,
I just say perl geturl.pl with index one.
I review that and I get some data.
What you see here are two docsum records.
The first one here.
And the nice thing is it works.
In the past this would have given an error.
I get my accession back and get my record
back.
For those of you that are parsing docsums
you might want to be aware we have a new tag
within the docsums called Accession.version.
That thing is brand new and it has the accession.version
in it.
That is something you can parse out directly
and that's where the identifier is now.
Of course the GI numbers going to be there
also.
And again, if it doesn't have a G.I. number,
ESummary can't find it.
That's how esummary's going to work.
Now esearch.
Two ESearch calls, one will look for foxp2[title]
and the other one has human[organism] without
$idtype=acc.
The other one as $idtype=acc appended.
So let's do the first one.
As I was showing in the slides, this is what
I get back; I get 48 things back.
Here is the top 20; I get gi numbers.
All I have to do is add that ID type equals
acc in that URL and i get back the accessions.
It is quick and simple.
All right, going on, ELink.
We can do elink just as we did esearch, linking
from a nuccore record to a protein record.
Here is the id.
It's also NM_001126, so we will do it both
ways.
Just know you have to include idtype=acc at
the end, if I'm going to do the accession.
So my first elink call, again, has the G.I.
number as input and gives me the gi number
for the output for the protein.
If I do idtype=acc, here is the NM_ as the
input, the NP_ is the output.
You can do this if you are linking across
from non-sequence to sequence databases.
So if I'm going from pubmed to nuccore or
pubmed into protein, you will use idtype=acc.
And, of course, PubMed will not have an accesion
number.
That's fine.
You'll use pmid's as your input to ELink but
the output from ELink will be accession numbers
in protein space.
That will all work just fine.
All right.
Let's take a look at the last ones here.
Here is EFetch.
Here is some of that Norway Spruce data.
This is WGS data that we've not been able
to give you before with EFetch.
That URL, here is the ID, that long accession,
the accession for the contig.
And I'm going to get FASTA back.
So I do that.
Boom, there is the FASTA for that wgs contig
and if I scroll up to the top, there it is,
Picea abies.
There is the data, it has a contig name.
All of this little FASTA definition line is
something we are providing.
It doesn't exist in Entrez, but we are providing
one to you.
And so here it is, you can get those data.
It's very likely if you want the entire project,
ftp might be a better method.
But, this is a way you can get contig by contig
if you want to get a set of contigs down from
one of these sets.
Last but not least, ESummary as a check.
How do I check to see whether my sequence
has a G.I. number?
I'm going to try ESummary with the CBVK.
The same accession of just retrieved with
efetch.
Let me see what happens.
But I'm going to try it in a mixed list of
other things; an NM_ record and a GenBank
record.
How would it look if I had a mixed list and
a bomb in their that doesn't have a G.I. number,
what is esummary going to do?
ESummary in the case where I just give it
that Norway Spruce wgs contig, it very politely
tells me, ERROR Invalid uid at this position.
I know that is the contig that had no UID.
If I give it the three identifiers, two of
which have GI numbers and one doesn't.
This is the data I get back.
At the top you see, ERROR Invalid uid at this
position.
And then I get the two valid docsums back
as expected.
So this should be a fairly rapid way to quickly
check a list of data to say what has gi's
and what doesn't.
This little Perl script, this almost brainlessly
simple Perl script.
It is on the FTP site and you can play with
it if you want.
If you have questions about any of that, we
will be taking them in a couple moments or
if you have questions later, write to us.
That will be my last statement before I be
quiet and we start discussing.
Continue to follow our social media posts,
blog, news, Facebook and Twitter accounts
for more updates and announcements about things
that will be happening with these sequence
resources, the changes with sequence identifier
space going forward.
The NCBI Learn page is a great place to come
for events like this if you want to have more
awareness of the webinars and other courses
that we are offering.
If you want to find out about the e-utility
updates, it's a great idea if you are using
them, please subscribe to utilities-announce@ncbi.
That's where we send out all of the announcements
about these upcoming changes, how you can
prepare for them.
Where we announce in advance that changes
changes are happening.
So it's a great place to look for those kinds
of things and keep yourself aware and not
be surprised.
Finally, info@ncbi is our general helpdesk.
Please don't hesitate to write to us if you
have questions or concerns.
All right I'm going to be quiet and open the
floor to questions.
This is Peter Cooper.
We do have a couple questions.
Eric.
Several of them I answered and you sort of
answered as you went through, so I won't go
over those again.
Those are the ones I answered in the questions
pod.
Interestingly people asked those questions
then immediately you said the answers to them.
Here's a few others.
The first one is about downloading WGS sequences
from the FTP site.
Given a top-level WGS project ID, so that's
essentially that prefix, what's the best way
to programmatically get the ftp location for
the entire assembly?
One way you can do that is to use the BioProject
database.
That has a good place to search for these
data sets.
That has metadata in it that will allow you
to find the project that is the source of
the WGS data.
You can link from BioProject into nuccore
and that will give you the master record,
if it's not in the BioProject data itself.
That's one avenue.
You then would be able to construct an FTP
URL down to the FTP site to get that data
from Genbank.
Another way you could approach that task of
getting the appropriate accession is through
nuccore itself.
At this point my understanding is that all
of our WGS projects -- or at least the vast
majority -- will be assigned a G.I. number
for their master record.
And that master record would be indexed with
some metadata.
So if you're trying to search organism or
a title or something like that, you may be
able to find it that way.
Then you can construct an FTP URL into Genbank.
I hope that helps.
If you want more detail on that, let us know
and we can provide you with some additional
suggestions.
I think the structure of the FTP site is a
formal way of doing that based on those accessions.
What I will do is put that -- I'll have to
look at it so I can describe it properly -- I
will put that in the Q&A document so everybody
can take a look at that.
The other question that I see here is can
esummary maintain the order of the input UID
even if there is a GI-less accession.version
in there?
That's a good question and one that we're
thinking about ourselves.
At the moment the order should be maintained
for those records that do have GIs.
It appears what's happening is we are writing
the errors at the top of the output screen.
So there's a disruption in the current order
of the input.
That's a good suggestion.
We will take that up with the development
staff and see if we can do something to address
that.
At the moment you're going to be stuck with
finding the errors at the top and the rest
should be in the order in which you submitted
them.
All right.
Thank you all very much for your time and
for attending.
Good luck out there and let us know if you
run into problems or have concerns or suggestions
about these new functions.
Thank you very much and have a great day.